so good morning everyone and thank
joining me my name is Alex Mackey and
this morning we're going to be
discussing a brief history of cloud now
all the slides and materials I'm going
to present will be available on my
website afterwards I've got detailed
references in some of the notes if you
want to explore some of these areas
further I work as a principal consultant
for the newly formed Telstra purple
prior to this better known may be
organization as a ridah fight so when we
talk about cloud computing we're going
to also need to talk about the history
of a number of other things as without
these things cloud computing really
wouldn't be possible so this morning
we're going to touch on a lot of
different things we're going to talk
about some of the history of
telecommunications and the internet
we're going to talk about protocols now
these are really important in the we're
going to need some of these things in
place in order to have modern-day
internet and cloud computing we're going
to talk about the history of computing
itself and various hardware advances and
then finally some of these things
wouldn't be possible without various
investments from business and we're also
going to touch on that
now I'm gonna split this presentation
into four main areas what I'm referring
to is prehistoric and it is prehistoric
in the terms of cloud computing so I
mean no comments sir if you were born in
some of these specific areas moving all
the way through to the future and then
we'll talk about where things might be
going later on now I should probably
begin what for some sort of definition
as to what cloud computing is in order
that we can get everyone on the same
page I kind of like Microsoft's
definition and they say simply put cloud
computing is a delivery of computing
services including servers storages
databases networking software analytics
and intelligence over the internet or
the cloud it's offer faster innovation
flexible resources and economies of
scale so this morning when I'm using the
term cloud computing I'm talking about
everything for running infrastructure in
the cloud functions and the cloud
software all of it we're gonna we're
gonna talk a little bit about of all
these things add this morning before we
delve into this I want to talk about
something called the narrative fallacy
and this refers to a tendency that as
human beings we love stories stories are
great they help us communicate
things and they help us understand
things now we also like to naturally
believe that B follows a and C follows B
and there's kind of this linear
progression of things where this can go
wrong however is that sometimes it can
increase what we think our level of
understanding of some of these concepts
are now the reality of this presentation
is that is that I've got about an hour
or so to cover a heap of things I've had
to pick various items and then try and
weave this into some kind of tale for
you this morning so just be aware that
there's very many more things and I'm
going to be talking about this morning
that all if you map them out there'd be
this kind of all these sort of Wiggly
lines intersected and so on which all go
and contribute to where we are today so
how did cloud computing begin well we
could probably begin with mr. Charles
Babbage and his analytical engine but if
we start at this point whilst very
interesting early computer history we're
gonna be here all day so I'm gonna have
to skip over some of these things so
sorry mr. Charles we won't be talking
about you today
and we won't be talking about the work
of Ada Lovelace and a huge number of
other characters which will also create
various innovations and developments
they'll all be necessary for cloud
computing let's go into what I'm gonna
refer to as their prehistoric cloud
computing era now for me I think these
things started off around the Cold War
this is a period in the 1950s and
there's this conflict between at the
time the Soviet Union various satellite
states and the US and it's a cold war in
that there's never any direct Russian
soldiers shooting American soldiers but
each sides are supporting various
initiatives that will impact or hurt the
other in some way maybe they're
supporting various regimes which have
interests in their favor and as a heap
of sort of espionage and things going on
behind the scenes here now at this point
in time the Americans very much believed
they had a technical superpower of the
day they believe they have the most
advanced science the most advanced
scientists the engineers and so on and
that they're leading the world in these
type of developments so it comes as
something of a surprise to them
when they hear this sound they don't
know what this sound is that's all right
so the Russians succeed in putting a
satellite into low orbit in 1957 and it
shatters the Americans perception that
they're the most technically events race
at this point and this creates a bit of
a problem for the administration under
the Eisenhower administration the focus
of American government changes and
various funding is put into science and
technology programs it's going to have
massive impacts and this launch of this
satellite and one of the things that
comes out of this is the organization
NASA of course NASA focused on all
things space now the one we're
interested in in this instance however
is ARPA and that's the advance research
and Projects Agency it's later going to
be renamed DARPA or the Defense Advanced
Research and Projects Agency and the
purpose of this is that it's formed for
forming an executing research and
development projects to expand the
frontiers of Technology and science and
able to reach far beyond immediate and
military requirements so what's going on
in the world of networking and so on at
this time well 1958 sees the
introduction of modems and
depend on data to inform 10 sounds and
these are important because this allows
existing telecoms infrastructure to be
used with actually valid trance
data between different machines there's
also an argument that there was
something looks good ugly and classified
a modem a little bit earlier which was
encrypting communication system the
Americans said about building this thing
called sage which is a semi-automatic
ground environment now the purpose of
this massive thing here is that it's
going to provide a unified view of the
airfield and so it's going to track up
to 400 or so Russian bombers which
theoretically could be coming over to
bomb the United States of course any
nation capable of putting a satellite
into orbit could theoretically launch
missiles which is what the Americans are
afraid of at this time so this thing
here houses one of the largest computers
ever built the ANF sq7
22,000 foot it's an enormous amount of
money to develop and costing 61 billion
and development over six years
it's also made up of 23 different
buildings that are all feeding in
various sort of information about you
know where these bombers and so are so I
think we see a very early example here
of kind of a distributed system here all
of this is linked together via modems
now sage is also going to be used in for
a commercial use one of the first
airline booking systems later on let's
go back there's a guy called Paul Baran
and he's becoming concerned that
communications could be taken out for
many hours by a year nuclear attack and
he sets about designing a survivable
communication system if we consider this
central node here this yellow node here
as routing various communications if
this was to take out then these other
four blue dots could not talk to one
another so what was interested in this
and he puts forward that if you create
additional connections and he puts
forward the idea that if there are at
least three connections between nodes
even in the event of a 50% loss of nodes
it's going to still end up being a
survivable communication system and this
stuff and these ideas are important
because they're going to lead to
something called packet switching which
is going to lead to reliable
communications near an Internet later
so this kind
it's myth kicking around that you've
probably heard that the internet was
designed to survive nuclear war I want
to read out part of a quote from a guy
called Charles Hetfield who's one of the
directors at ARPA and he says the
ARPANET was not started to create a
command and control system that would
survive a nuclear attack as many now
claim to build such a system was clearly
a major military need but it was not our
first mission to do this in fact we
would have been severely criticized have
we tried Rover the ARPANET came out of
our frustration that they were only a
limited number of large powerful
research computers in the country and
the many research invest cases who
should have access to them were
geographically separated from them so
this will get onto this in a minute but
this is this system and network is not
created around a community level
communication system this is not the
motivations for this I want to introduce
you to this guy because he's gonna be
very important in the development of the
internet and cloud computing and this is
JCR Licklider he liked to be called Lick
which is very much easier to pronounce
so I'm gonna go with that and lick has a
background in something called
psychoacoustics Lick is very interested
in how sounds get interpreted by the ear
and understood by the brain and he
starts to put forward some really
important ideas and what are the things
that's quite important is at this point
it looks like everyone's handing over
decision-making into computers because
computers could perform certain types of
decisions very much quicker and liquids
forward this idea that actually we can
make some better decisions if we involve
humans in this decision-making process
so Nick is hired to connect a number of
Department of Defense computers and
during this period he comes up with this
concept called the intergalactic
computer network in 1960 I'm gonna read
this out because it is absolutely
pivotal to some future development and
he says it seems reasonable to envisage
for a time 10 or 15 years hence a
thinking sensor they'll incorporate the
functions of present-day libraries
together with anticipated advances in
information storage and retrieval this
picture readily enlarges itself into a
network of such centers connected to one
another by wideband communication lines
and to individual users by Lee
wire services it's such a system the
speed of the computers we balanced and
the cost of gigantic memories and
sophisticated programs would be divided
by the number of users now does that
sound like a couple of modern-day
servers i remind these ideas are
absolutely revolutionary this is 1960
none of the technology currently exists
in order to implement and build some of
these ideas here I think there's a
stronger argument that we could consider
lick the father of the Internet and
indeed cloud computing so we move
forward in time to 1963 and it's now
become head of the behavioral sciences
and command and control programs there
too up up and he starts talking about
these ideas of this intergalactic
network where some of his colleagues and
he convinces a couple of his colleagues
Ivan Sutherland and Bob Taylor that this
thing's really important and we need to
focus on this as an organization and say
this is going to lead to the creation of
ARPANET now current state-of-the-art
computing is that thing over there on
the left that beauty over there is the
IBM 1442 card punch machine and when
people want to go and schedule various
programs to be run it requires a
specialist operator who will order up
these punch cards programs and feed into
this a machine people start coming to
the realization that maybe we're not
making full usage of computers at this
point and people like John Backus start
considering this concept of time sharing
and we can see here in this quote from
1958 that we start seeing this idea of
computing and processing as kind of a
utility organizations would have
input/output equipment installed on
their own premises and would buy time on
a computer much the same way that the
average household by his power and water
from utility companies 1958 these ideas
are being put forward so it takes a bit
of time before we start getting a
modern-day time-sharing
operating system and this is a really
difficult problem at the time very
limited hardware and it's a very tough
problem because as you go and switch
between different applications or
programs you're going to need to store
the state of what these things are
somewhere but
this is eventually solved with the
introduction of the first time sharing
system CTE SS by John McAfee at MIT and
later we see DTS s or the Dhamma of
time-sharing system released three or
four years later in 1963 it's an
important project going on over at Ann
Arbor funded project researching various
aspects of computing and they want to
look at things like AI computational
theory and so on and the academics put
forward all of these ideas but they
realized that at the time current
Hardware is not going to support and be
able to run some of these sort of
revolutionary ideas so they put out a
proposal to the largest hard drive
manufacturers at the time which are
General Electric's and IBM they say hey
we need to help building these ideas of
us
IBM respond saying they didn't want to
develop a time-sharing computer as they
did not feel there was big enough to met
they did kind of redeem themselves later
with the introduction of the first
mainframe to support virtualization but
this project Mac is going to make some
important contributions to compete in
history but we've got this idea of this
network now but it's not been built it's
all in theory it's all in people's heads
and it's going to need to be built so
they put out this proposal to some of
the contractors the day but it's seen as
crazy like no one's done this stuff and
built this large-scale network before so
people aren't so keen in potentially
building this but it will eventually be
built by an organization called BBN or
bolt burnick and newman and they said
about connecting one computer in Utah
with free over in California now they
want to do this because it's all about
sharing of scientific information and
then one fateful evening in 1969 via
this new network that's recently been
built they successfully managed to
transmit the first word and they
transmitted login and by Charlie Klein
at 10:30 and he sends this from UCLA and
to the Stanford Research Institute or s
RI although he doesn't actually send
login because it crashes after they send
the first two letters there so
the first word is actually ello you can
theorize that maybe he was sending lol
but who who knows they do eventually get
this working a couple of hours later
though and the word is successfully
transmitted and they're on the phone to
each other saying can you see the L can
you see the O and you can imagine the
excitement at the time I think and this
is a picture of the log here and it's
kind of understated in the you know this
hasn't been done using this network
before talk to SR I host the host 10:30
there
now open it it's not the easiest thing
to use and it's all academics using this
thing it's focused on the sharing of
scientific information and the knowledge
of how to use it is spread very much by
people it's academics moving from
university to college moving around the
place and saying this is how you work
with this introducing other academics
and to some of the facilities and
they've got this problem at the moment
that it's really hard to go and make
improvements to the network so they set
up this thing called a network working
group and out of this we get the RFC
process which we still use today they
introduced a protocol and called NCP or
network control protocol which is going
to make it easier to communicate between
some of these machines 1969 sees
CompuServe I found it I think CompuServe
are probably better known as an ISP but
they're actually founded way back in
1969 and they're founded in order to
provide computer processing support and
to an insurance company and I think
they're also one of the first people
they notice that their machine another
time very expensive hardware at this
time isn't actually doing anything so
they go and sell this and to other
corporations later what else is going on
well there's a number of other networks
in development around the world here we
see the introduction of the MPL network
in the UK a lower net in Hawaii HL in
for a consortium Airlines and also
another one called Cyclades which is
going to be quite influential and to
what will become the Internet so as we
move on from prehistoric cloud era we've
now got reliable telephone
basic communications we have modems we
have an RFC process I really can't
emphasize how important this RFC process
is going to be this is going to be an
important way to establish and share new
ideas we're very much in the era of
expensive mainframes as well and
computers are currently costing around
five million dollars or so so only very
large organizations can afford to
purchase some of these machines the
network at the moment is solely focused
on academic and government use
commercial use is absolutely out the
picture at the moment let us move on to
cloud Middle Ages or the period between
1970 and 1990 so this diagram here shows
the development of the ARPANET here and
you can see between the period of 1969
and 1977 how quickly this networks going
to grow as we start seeing the linking
up of various educational and sort of
government's establishments here they
run a demo and it must have been
absolutely amazing at the time where
they go and demonstrate network traffic
remote login editing a text file and a
computer mouse but our first focus is
not on running a year network but that's
what's starting to take up an increasing
amount of their time and resources as
people find this the useful thing so the
defense communications agency end up
taking control of ARPANET in 1975 1977
we see what's known as the first
commercial local network at Chase
Manhattan Bank in New York using a token
ring architecture and apparently able to
support up to 255 computers personal
computers they start to become
affordable somewhat expensive in terms
of between four and five thousand US
dollars in one day adjusted terms but
they're just about in reach of maybe
some more wealthy individuals here
change recommand
I think is an important one that's worth
mentioning that's introduced in 1979 now
this is a UNIX based command that allows
you to change the route directory for
running process
it's children and this is the beginning
of being able to isolate programs the
different file systems and some of these
approaches and developments are going to
lead to later things such as containers
kubernetes and so on they were kind of
started to take for granted today now at
the moment ARPANET machines they're
using a protocol called 18 to 2 in order
to talk to one another has anyone heard
of that protocol no it's not one I'd
come across the IVA and the other main
protocol they're using is NCP but these
protocols have an issue they're not very
good they're very good for talking
direct from one host to another but when
you start linking networks together and
networks of networks or internet works
they have some problems here so a
different approach and solution is
needed so in 1983 we see tcp/ip
replacing NCP as our pinettes main
protocol with tcp/ip been developed by
Vint Cerf and Bob Kahn 1983 we see the
introduction of DNS from Paul maka
Petrus and Jon Postel and the important
thing about these protocols is that we
can now hide the differences between all
these disparate networks by their by
their abstractions now around 1983 the
military starts become a little bit
concerned with the potential security
issues around the use of ARPANET so they
spin off this other network called
MILNET and it contains some additional
protection such as encryption and so on
now around this time a number of other
organizations start developing their own
networks including the National Science
Foundation NSF and they'll develop
something called an NSF net NASA
department of energy and all of these
things will eventually become the
modern-day internet and somewhat sadly
we see the decommissioning of ARPANET in
1989 now I came across this quote here
and this is by an MIT member of staff
and they start to become concerned that
what people are going to use or are
using ARPANET for and they say that
sending an electronic mail over up a net
for commercial profit or political
purposes is both antisocial and illegal
by sending such messages you can offend
many people and it's possible to get MIT
in serious trouble with the
agencies which manage the ARPANET so
bear in mind all of these things
academic and government focus at the
time it's sort of the idea of these
things being used for commercial use is
a scary idea for these people of course
we know how that's going to end out 1989
and sees the creation of the world's
first ISP by a new jersey-based company
and they introduced this is be called
the world and this is controversial at
the time because no one's done this
before
and a number of different governments
and universities threatened to block
access from the world because you know
on the grounds that said this network
was not intended for commercial use over
in Australia we see the registration of
the au top-level domain to Kevin ELLs
it's a Melbourne University and
Australia gets its own ISPs which
depending on who you talk to
it's probably either dialects or Pegasus
Network foundation over in 1989 this is
the era of the early internet services
and we're seeing the establishment of
various ISPs such as CompuServe prodigy
AOL we're sending out their discs to
everyone but at the moment some of this
stuff is not very easy to use and it's
not really doing what people want but
this is about to change with the work of
visco so Tim berners-lee or Sir Tim
whilst at CERN in Switzerland he Christ
a couple of proposals and these are
going to go on to become the world wide
web in 1989 and I think you can argue
that he combined hypertext tcp/ip and
DNS in order to create the world wide
web and on Christmas 1990 he has a
running prototype of this on a next
computer now it's going to take a little
bit of time before this is sort of
starts to reach outside academic circles
so as we move on from this sort of
Middle Ages of cloud
we've got reliable and fast comms
infrastructure we've got essential
protocols tcp/ip DNS HTTP we still use
these today these are almost 40 years
old some of these protocols a really
important factor for us however is that
developments in processing power and
computers means that computers are now
affordable to
individuals and they're costing around
$1,200 dollars depending on what you're
buying now if you need to do any sort of
hosting of network and stuff it's been
done in-house you've probably got some
kind of server in a cupboard somewhere
in your company let us move on to
modern-day cloud computing so this graph
here this is from the American Census
Bureau that purple line there represents
people that have a computer and that
blue line there represents computers
with an internet subscription the other
lines there are from a similar survey
and what you can see over here is that
around about this period 97 mm this is
about to increase dramatically all the
way up to and this ended 2015 here where
we have about 80 percent of households
with a computer an internet connection
and I'd guess that it's probably going
to be even higher today so we're about
to see an a huge increase in terms of
computers and demand on the Internet the
Internet's not the easiest thing to use
at the moment but it's changes with the
release of mosaic in 1993 and the great
thing about this is it's really easy to
use and it also displays multimedia
content it's not just plain text anymore
so this is going to excite a number of
people Bill Gates
so Bill's watching what's happening with
this and there's no doubt that builds a
very clever guy and he releases
something that's known as the internet
tidal wave memo I'd encourage you to
Google this as it makes quite
interesting reading
it come starts off with Bill has a
somewhat bit of a rant to be honest
where he can't find any Microsoft
formats on the Internet he can't find
which is somewhat entertaining but look
builds a clever guy and he starts to get
an idea of where things are going at
this point and I pulled out a couple of
comments there we need to understand how
to make NT boxes the highest performance
HTTP servers our server offerings need
to be what Netscape is doing including
Bill in the security support there were
substantial demand for high transaction
servers so can Bill can see where this
stuff is going I think there's an
argument over whether Microsoft we're
able to execute on this for a while but
way back in
ninety-five bill bill can see what we're
rare this is likely going this is the
era of the dot-com boom it's very easy
to raise money for companies there's a
lot of potential in terms of an
increased number of people using the
Internet increased number of devices
internet users and so on and then
there's also a number of combination of
other factors such as low interest rates
lowered capital gains tax and so on that
make it really easy to get some money
and of course we also have investors may
be ignoring some traditional business
metrics such as cash flow people maybe
get a little bit excited and greedy
there's massive infrastructure
investments going on as well at this
time people see where things are going
here and anticipate a huge demand we see
the largest ever IPO at this time with
Netscape launching with a value of 2.9
billion dollars Jeff Bezos say I called
Jeff and he founds an organization
called Cadabra dot Inc and the story is
that's just solicitor looked at this
name and mistook it for Kodava and said
look company named after a dead body
it's maybe not the best name for your
company and they've ever think about
this and they decide they're gonna go
and rename their organization
Jeff quite likes the name relentless and
but they do end up settling on Amazon
and the rumor is that a correlate to
Amazon because a it appears at the top
of the list and a tizzy
so at this point Amazon is focused on
selling books online that is what Jeff
wants to do he has never ideas he just
wants to sell books online at this point
and of course he's going to later expand
that out into other areas we see the
earliest use or the earliest known use
of the term cloud computing in 1996 by a
guy called George favela and he put
forward this business plan for a compact
where he uses this term at this point
when you buy a bit of software it's like
buying a product from the shelf so you
might remember some of
there was no real sort of subscription
or licensing model you'd go to a store
you'd penned your money over you'd get
your software and that would be it you
would own that software here now this is
about to be change and while Salesforce
certainly weren't the first people to
try this model I think they were
arguably the first really successful
company to put forward that actually a
subscription model can work in order to
go and sell software and they're still
very much successful today we start
seeing increased mobile usage at this
point in time and it gets to the point
where pretty much everyone has a mobile
your parents have a mobile you probably
remember this I mean your own lifetime
and all of this is starting to create
increased demand for services and so on
prior to this computers they weren't
affordable now they're affordable and
now we've also got Mobile's and we've
got increasing devices here and we're
putting more and more load and demand on
some of the services that we're using of
course in the early days of sort of
mobile internet the services were
somewhat crappy and you might remember
some of those text-based was it websites
I think so at this point hosting were in
the era of large data centers and the
way it might work is you might go and
place an order with Dell or Compaq and
it would take somewhere between 8 and 12
weeks and then you'd get a server even
directly or you'd go and install it in
the hosting center yourself and I
remember driving out to various hosting
centers and putting servers in the rack
this isn't the quickest process you know
that's a free month lead time for some
of these things and it's really not
going to work for some of these
organizations and with all these
increasing people having internet access
and so on there's increasing demands
here at the time so we're going to need
another way of keeping up with this and
now with a period around sort of 2000
2001 and as we know with any sort of
increase or boom at some point that's
also going to decline and sooner or
later the dot-com bubble does of course
burst and by the end of this bubble
analysts will estimate between five and
seven
in dollars will be lost although I think
there's an argument as to whether this
actually existed in the first place out
of people's head so what happened well
that could certainly be the subject of a
presentation itself but largely speaking
I think companies were probably
overvalued people who used metrics that
ignored cash flow and we had a keep of
other things such as changes in interest
rates Japanese recession accountants and
directors doing dodgy things at
world.com and Enron and of course the
September 11 events around this period
but the output of this is that there's a
lot less money around time for people to
go and invest with and build companies
with investors are very cautious now
it's no longer enough that you've got
a.com in your name in order to go and
get a lot of money we see large layoffs
of tech staff and increasing focus on
the bottom line amma's in at this point
I focused on creating something called
merchant comm and this is kind of gonna
be a shopping engine and the idea is
they're gonna handle some of your order
ordering processing and some of the
logistics around this somewhat
ironically they're trying to sell it to
I believe people like Walmart at this
time and of course Amazon and Walmart
will become kind of archenemies in what
they do later but Amazon is growing
really quickly the company's expanded
far beyond selling just books at this
point in time and they're saying going
into a lot of other markets and so on
but they've kind of come across this
classic problem that we all know that
you can't just increase the speed of
development by adding additional
developers and to a project it just
doesn't work and I said about start
splitting their codebase into
independent services and we see sort of
very early sort of approaches to sort of
service orientated architecture and so
on around this there's kind of this myth
that AWS came out of unused
infrastructure that maybe Jeff or one of
his team looked around and he said I've
got all these servers sitting around and
they're not being used hey we can make
some money out of selling this excess
capacity this didn't actually happen so
two people Chris Pinkman pictured over
on the left there and another person
called Benjamin black they produce this
paper where they start thinking about
different services you need to put
together various applications and they
kind of propose an operating system for
the internet and they put forward this
proposal to the organization suggesting
that they could generate revenue from
this infrastructure back in 2003 and
Jeff Bezos says we've realized we can
contribute all of the key components
that internet operating system and with
that we went to pursue this much broader
mission which is AWS today which is
really to allow any organization or
company or any developer to run their
technology applications on top of our
technology infrastructure platform and I
think this is important because I think
that AWS probably allowed a number of
companies to exist which wouldn't have
been possible without a different sort
of payment model for their services
prior to this you would have needed
enormous amounts of money to go and buy
physical machines and so on and you kind
of get that this sort of vicious cycle
where in order to get more investment
you're going to need to demonstrate
you've got more customers and you can't
do that because you need more money in
order to purchase more hosting equipment
and not have your servers fall over and
so on so yes I think AWS if we didn't
have AWS or something similar a number
of companies wouldn't exist today so
they launched so a service called sqs
simple queue service which is obviously
still around today way back in 2004 and
by 2006 they've kind of got their main
offerings of simple storage or s3 and
Elastic Compute cloud and this launched
in a u.s. market first of all with the
rest of the world a little bit later and
by 2010 all of Amazon's infrastructure
is running on AWS services now as we
know Amazon is a hugely popular site and
this sort of dog feeding of their own
services enabled them to you know focus
on the developing a very reliable
high-performance infrastructure 2008
sees the launch of Google cloud with app
engine whilst it has some user I don't
think it ever really sort of receives
the popularity of some of the other
cloud-based services
2009 who tote of Alibaba yep so Alibaba
world's largest retailer and commerce
company and you know they've got a huge
to need for servers and hosting
equipment and they very very large but
mostly in China at this perspective now
I think these guys are one to watch at
the moment and I'll come back to this
shortly but you might be asking what is
Microsoft during a tall list like
enormous company of enormous resources
all these other competitors have
launched what are they up to
well in about 2007 corporate VP Amitabh
ah sure esta sure reversed our apologies
for your pronunciation of your name he's
asked and tasked to create a cloud
platform and he could recruit some real
heavyweights including David Cutler the
father of NT and VMs system and they
create this thing called Project Red Dog
now the rumor is that Red Dog refers to
some dodgy bar um that's some of the
team frequented and you can still make
see mention of Red Dog if you go and
spin up a VM in the computer name there
you'll see the prefix Rd at the
beginning so we still sort of has its
origins over there now as you won't be
released till 2010 and it begins as a
fork of the Windows Server 2008
operating system Microsoft kind of
unique in that you know they own and
develop an operating system so it makes
sense to use this but it doesn't have
all the capabilities that they need in
order to run a cloud computing platform
so the team said about adding a few
things to it including a programming
model support for booting from VHD and
support for acorn machines now at this
point it's a fork of the 2008 codebase
and as we know that's going to be quite
expensive to maintain
so it's later going to come back in line
with Server 2012 ray Yazzie announces as
you're at PDC in 2008 but we don't see
Windows Azure officially released
publicly to 2010 and that's a full four
years after Amazon have sort of released
its foundation or services so Microsoft
are definitely a little bit slow and
into this game they're kind of realizing
that they're going to want to host some
other things they've renamed Windows
Azure to Microsoft Azure later in 2014
and I think we see quite a change in
Microsoft direction and Satya Nadella is
leadership when he takes over and we
started to see Microsoft embracing for
his competitors products and you might
have seen some of the news that the most
used operating system on Azure is now
linux-based Azure is also interesting in
that it appeals to some Amazon
competitors if you're someone like
Walmart it doesn't really make sense for
you to be giving Amazon money by hosting
your stuff on AWS 2013 and we see the
release of docker and kubernetes now I
think these are important technologies
because this is the beginning of being
able to abstract various extract the
hosting of various services and this
brings us up to today so in terms of
current trends as a consultant and we
get the chance to work for a lot of
different organizations and these are
some of the things that I see and I've
got out to some of my colleagues
industry experts and said hey what do
you think's going on at the moment and
with some of these things we see a trend
towards multi-cloud now a lot of
organizations kind of end up with multi
cloud whether they like it or not with
people should have spinning up various
things in their own time or various
services that they want to play with but
for some organizations a multi cloud
strategy is mandated if you're a
financial organization you need to run
on more than one cloud or a certain type
of financial organization I should say
multi cloud it's hard enough to run
really well on one cloud let alone
bringing in a whole different sort of
heap of technologies and so on it's my
owner advice would be if you don't need
to probably just focus on the one cloud
get that right initially before you
start introducing these and of course
people hope to gain various sort of
things by running on multiple clouds
such as increased redundancy the
abilities in the goshi a price with
vendors there's kind of this fear that
when a vendor Caesar you're running all
your your stuff on one cloud
that's you won't have any room for price
negotiation and so on
we've seen increased use of abstractions
people don't want to be looking after
the infrastructure themselves you no
doubt come across service architecture
approaches and and so on competitors
embracing each other's technology I was
reading this week about some offerings
on AWS to make it improve support for
dotnet I think as it's kind of like the
default choice if you've got a dotnet
application and it's a good choice
Microsoft makes it very tempting with
some of the tooling and capabilities but
whilst you can certainly run abs on the
applications in AWS it's maybe not quite
as easy until sort of recent donate core
stuff managing cost in cloud and
enterprise level is really hard
especially if you're running on multiple
clouds and I think there's gonna be a
need for better focus of this and I also
suspect if some organizations looked at
just how much they were spending on
cloud in detail they might want to maybe
spend a bit of time looking at what's
actually running there I think we'll
just see as well increased legislation
and even government interference in some
areas such as backdoors and so on in
order to access dada if we were to ask
who has the biggest cloud at the moment
one answer would be Microsoft and I say
one answer because whilst they report
the highest level of revenue this is
back in 2018 when Microsoft go and talk
about how much they make from cloud
they also lumpy in a number of other
services such as office 365 LinkedIn and
so on and you can go and download their
annual report and look in detail at some
of these things now what's these
services yes some of these are delivered
over the cloud and they're cloud-based
services
if you terms have been able to compare
sort of infrastructure I'm not sure
really they should be included in there
and you know that that winner there is
undoubtedly Amazon as reported by
multiple analyst I don't think it
ultimately matters who but what I do
will think I want to draw your attention
see is that there's still rather a lot
of stuff not running in the cloud as
probably a number of different
applications which are starting to reach
end-of-life around about now
and there might be a good opportunity to
go and move some of these things to the
cloud the cloud probably didn't exist
when some of these things were created
in the first place what's the initial
sort of focus of various cloud-based
businesses was very much on
infrastructure I think this is starting
to turn towards data whether it's the
storage of your data performing
analytics on your data or the management
of your data and to people I would watch
in this area IBM and Alibaba cloud now
Alibaba in particular I think are gonna
be particularly interesting some of the
things they're doing in this area some
of you might have seen some of their
visual pay and recognition stuff they
have a massive investment in this space
at the moment IBM they've got some very
material products such as Watson and so
on and so whilst these are maybe
probably not so well named known names
in the cloud world I would watch what
these people are doing at the moment
in fact with for Alibaba we see Alibaba
actually releasing an unveiling their
own AI focus chip here so we now have a
ecommerce giant cloud hosting company
actually releasing their own Hardware
focused on ai and visual processing here
and that's kind of cool but what do we
have in store for the future well you
probably come across this quote here
where we ask why you study in history
importance in the first place and you've
probably come across some variation of
this in the those who cannot remember
the past are condemned to repeat it or
perhaps as Stephen Hawking more
cynically puts it we spend a great deal
of time studying history which let's
face it is mostly the history of
stupidity I'd like to introduce you this
model I came across fairly recently and
he says the futures came and what this
demonstrates is that if we took a
concept such as landing on the moon at
one point prior to that has been done
this is considered an impossible
activity it's so far out there in terms
of the realms of possibility then it
sounds an absolutely crazy idea if we're
going to start talking about doing this
but of course we know now that it is
possible and that people can land on the
moon and from that a number of other
things are possible if we were to extend
this path here we can see some of the
current trends around multi-cloud
increased use of abstractions containers
and so on and we can probably extend out
to where that's going in some degree we
see the introduction from Google cloud
of an force platform to make some of
this stuff easier I think that's
probably going to be a focus of a number
of organizations but what we sometimes
have as well is we have these wild card
things that really sort of you know can
have an influence and change where
things are going in terms of a direction
things like the introduction of
containers while it was built on a heap
of technology it took a while before
people really understood the
implications and this was popularized
through the use of things like docker
and so on but that obviously has a big
potential to very much change the
direction of where these things are
going we've seen that many different
factors have influenced the development
of the cloud we've talked about various
scientific and technical advances we've
talked about the creation of various
standards we've talked about the
worldwide economy we had the dot-com
boom we have people buying more
computers we have demanding to go and
use some of these services there's also
need like a lot of this was driven by
academics early in the picture wanting
to share information between one another
and not really having access to the
resources that they needed in order to
do their work they want to be sharing
their experiments with people so they
start looking at what's the solution for
all this we're going to see various
changes in legislation around the open
up of infrastructure and so on if what's
going to pick one had maybe the biggest
influence in terms of the development I
think this is need one like a lot of us
has come out of a genuine need or
perhaps perceived need for a solution
here but the interaction of all of these
factors is that what's makes is what
makes it hard to actually predict where
this is going and this is a simplified
picture that I've given you and this
morning
but let's have a go anyway so let's have
seven predictions as where some of this
stuff is going I think that's very much
a need to abstract cloud services I
think there's now kind of a core set of
capabilities that all cloud providers
have whilst there's various differences
between them there's always some type of
computes there's always some type of
storage and there's always some type of
message queue or function to operate on
these things it would be very much
easier if there was an abstraction to go
and work with these things and I know
we've seen the development of some of
these things with you know various
libraries and frameworks but I think
this work today I think we're gonna want
to move Dada between some of these
services you might have everything
sitting on Azure now but you want to use
Google's bigquery and right now there's
not really a good way to go and move
data around between some of these
services currently it's very much up to
you to suggest what's the right
configuration for your workload and
services I think we're in the early days
have some intelligence around this but I
think companies at the moment don't
really have a clear picture is just how
much some of these services are costing
them and that we might see some
intelligence around this where as your
AWS or whatever your your platform of
hosts is looks at what you're doing and
says hey we could potentially scale this
down for you or have you considered this
way of doing things because I think
customers become more and more demanding
when they realize how much money on some
of these things is being spent
efficiency of data centers I think is
going to become increasingly important
there's this writing called PUA and our
p/e of one means you have a perfectly
efficient data center and we have
current trends and hopefully it will
continue where we start to look at some
of the environmental impacts of some of
these things and as well as the
environmental impact there's also a cost
impact in if you can produce a very
efficient data center it means you're
consuming less power and you can
potentially be more profitable as well
so you might have come across some of
the news around some of underwater
hosted containers and so on so it'll be
interesting to see where that goes
I think it would make sense for some
very large organized
to potentially run their own clout and
some of them are maybe even doing this
who already if you're a Walmart or
something whilst it's no easy feat to
you know just set up and learn your own
cloud and these several organizations
have certainly learn the lessons the
hardware the hard way I think it can
make financial sense to invest in some
of these rather than pay someone else to
go and run in some of these things I
think we're probably going to see the
rise of Alibaba cloud here but only for
some industries now there's a bit of
concern some of the stuff around Hawaii
and some of the links to Chinese
government and so on which are probably
going to mean that some industries or
organizations won't want to put their
stuff on Alibaba but it's very very
cheap and certainly if you've got some
you know personal services and stuff go
have a play with me I would encourage
you to go and have a look at it it is
still interesting noting that it's quite
early days for this so if some of the
documentation feels may be a little bit
clunky is not the easiest thing to read
and so on so it'll be interesting to see
where that goes the AI facilities and
functions that Alibaba are providing
though I think could potentially drive
uptake I think we see that with Google
Cloud from what I've seen that people
often you know look at some of their
products like bigquery or whatever and
that's the one that attracts people and
then they get on to using some of the
other services maybe it'll be the same
with some very Baba's offerings on
demand quantum computing ten years maybe
shorter now quantum computing category
yeah it's gonna be very very good for a
specific set of tasks and I think it
would make sense in terms of a cloud
model in terms of a cloud hosting
perspective to be able to give and as
your base to quantum computer a heap of
tasks to go and perform because it's
hardware initially is likely to be very
very expensive and specialists finally I
think it's probably only a matter of
time before we see a large-scale
compromise of a public cloud despite all
the controls and everything put in place
at some point this will likely happen
and it's likely to be through some
victor that we don't see right now
and this is quite terrifying because if
someone was to maybe compromise
something one of the large clouds
theoretically they could turn it against
another large cloud as well and it would
be absolute chaos in terms of the damage
that could be done hopefully that won't
happen but I certainly think it's the
possibility in summary I'm going to
propose the modern day cloud computing
probably started around the Cold War
period and was driven from this we've
seen how many different disparate
factors have Kant contributed to the
development of cloud computing I think
the changes have largely been driven by
a need of people and academics to share
information and to respond to requests
and I think we can also see with the
benefit of hindsight that if you were to
see all these things happening at the
time then it'd be very hard so it
predicts where things are going in the
future I'm gonna end it thank you very
much
does anyone have any questions
probably probably a number of factors I
think Microsoft had a number of
advantages say whether it was owning the
dotnet development systems they could
immediately encourage sort of uptake via
those routes
I think they invested a huge amount of
money in making things like as you are
very easy to use I didn't see that from
Google I remember and maybe it was just
some of those sort of conferences and
groups that I frequented that you'd see
a very notable presence from Microsoft
encouraging people to get on this they
introduced various programs for small
businesses there was a lot of sort of
investment and focus in that direction
and I just didn't see that from Google
they seem to be sort of taking a slower
route or maybe focused in a slightly
different area focusing on the data
stuff what do you think yeah and I think
Google's got a really interesting
strategy at the moment so Microsoft or
AWS tend to say put everything on us you
know everything on us now Google have
realized they're playing catch-up to
some degree and strategy they seem to be
employing and my opinion is that we can
also be your cloud it's not a you know
Eva or and for those industries in
particular where you need to be hosting
on multiple clouds Google have kind of
gone them with this approach that hey
you can also put our stuff and we're
going to make it really easy for you to
run an on our cloud as a product that's
called nforce that sort of it is
released now but it still seems to be in
development which is supposed to make it
very much easier to run and shift
containers between different house
hosting providers including eventually
Amazon a Microsoft and so on
um we'll look quantum computing I'm
certainly no expert in this area it's
very suited to a very specific type of
problem so you're not going to be
running your typical sort of line of
business application on it it's gonna be
problems like data modeling encryption
there's a certain type of algorithm
which paralyzes paralyzes that's right
weird but it can be run very efficiently
and receive sort of instant results when
run on a concern based machine there's a
guy called John Azariah he's on the
Microsoft team working on some of this
stuff and he has a talk at the
conference introducing the concepts of
quantum computing so I'd encourage you
to go to that talk and John will
certainly be very happy to answer that
what I think based on you know my very
basic knowledge of quantum computing we
might see is hey we've got this data
model or this computation that fits this
model can you go and run it that that
seems this sort of how it could
potentially work in my head well pretty
much all of the main vendors are
offering various AI based services on
demand so as your AWS they offer a huge
range of AI machine learning type stuff
everything from visual recognition all
your processing all of these types of
things what's also interesting I don't
know about AWS so so much but you can
create various models on Azure and then
deploy them to an edge device so you can
take this model that you had running in
the cloud and run it locally so you
might have some type of device doing
some visual recognition working in the
room and you can make use of that same
model that you've developed on the cloud
running on something like azure IOT edge
we don't have in the early days of I
guess sort of hosting and so on people
might run their their own servers and
what there's kind of some analogies to
maybe house house sort of utility
companies and power generation sort of
developed here in the some factories way
back they'd have their own sort of power
station actually running it and nowadays
you know some households they'll have
solar panels you could potentially buy a
bit of a solar grid system which is then
routed back to your home and this kind
of see this sort of similar model with
cloud hosting you can certainly still
run like a you know a server within your
office building there's some workloads
that make sense to be in the cloud and
the some workloads that make sense to be
processed on the edge somewhere and some
things that kind of sort of blur some of
those boundaries and sit in between I
think it's gonna be the same with some
of the AI stuff it's gonna depend you
know on your use case there's some stuff
that where it's great in the cloud under
some some stuff that you're gonna want
sort of likely
I like it it's certainly possible
Alibaba is the one I'm interested in
they've got a huge announced amounts of
resources and funding available you know
there's some clunky bits at the moment
the documentation may be in places
doesn't reads very well it's had sort of
limited uptake but they have what's
needed in order to you know popularize
there and they also have some things to
draw people in such as some of the AI
focus that they've had in terms of other
providers none on spring to mind at the
moment there's anyone else in the
audience come across anything
interesting the essentially looks
promising yeah there's some people that
I think have been rather quiet in this
face like Apple you know they'd the
enormous technology company sort of
money I wonder
holy or the infrastructure yeah I have
no idea I'd have to look that up for you
but it must be enormous amounts in terms
of cooling data centers running the
machines absolutely enormous and you
know as I mentioned a company but could
potentially become more profitable by
reducing some of these consumptions and
needs if you google PUA that's that
power rating you'll see some of the
writings that various people have
achieved and some of these ratings
they've had to have like a sort of an
independent person come and have a look
at and assess this is the actual rating
and there's various sort of
complications around do you count
lighting do you count this as you know
does this contribute to your PE rating
but I think I'll try find some resources
and I'll put it out on Twitter well I'm
gonna leave that there I'll put the
slides up thank you very much and for a
rest joining me enjoy the rest of your
day